today
国境なき医師団は
中立の立場で異形の届いていない場所に公平に陽動に医療を提供する団体です
日本にいるとその医療が届いていないという状況はなかなか想像がつきにくいかもしれ
ませんが
日本という小さな国から一歩
海を越えてみたときに
緊急的に医療が必要にも関わらず
医療のアクセスがない人々がたくさんいるという現実があるんですね
その医療が届いていないというその理由には例えばその地域に
王者祭や病院が少なかったり
また王者祭や病院はあるのだけれど
差別だったり
迫害を受けていて人々の偉業へのアクセスが断たれてしまっているような状況だったり
また医療へのアクセスはあるのだけれど
治療法のわからないような病気が蔓延して困っている状況などさまざまです
またそのような背景には自然災害の発生
それから感染症の蔓延
難民生活貧困などがあり風装置もその一つに挙げられます
私は日本とオーストラリアで10年以上の看護師の経験を積んできました
一口に看護師といっても働く分野は様々です
小児科内科
婦人科
外来
たくさんある中で私は激化や手術室での経験を多く積んできました
国境なき手段では私の経験が活かせる場所
ケガをして手術が必要な患者さんが多く運ばれる場所
つまり紛争地に派遣されることが多くなりました
そんな私は2010年に参加して以来
いいえ名やイラク
シリア
南スーダンパレ室など数多くの風装置で活動してきました
私が国境なき下に出会ったのは7歳の頃でした
医療に人種や国籍
政治的な心情だったりまた進行する酋長
それらの隔たりを乗り越えて平等に医療を提供する人々がいると知り
幼いながらにも心から尊敬と憧れの念を抱きました
その後私は看護師という素晴らしい職業に出会うことができ
私の人生の軸というのは看護師看護師が私の人生の宿となっていきました
100万人以上の看護師を抱える日本では
私一人が抜けたとしても医療体制が崩壊するなどということは考えられません
ところが骨頂なてぃ手段が入るような現場では
看護師1人が行けることで医療が回らなくなってしまう
そんなような場所がたくさんあるのだということを知りました
1人の医師
1人の看護師の価値はとても高まり
今まで医療が届いていなかった場所に医療を届けるという喜びを見出すことができまし
た
ところが
風葬中波形を重ねるうちに
そのような喜びは
次第に
憤りだったり怒り
挫折や無力感へとつながっていきました
紛争地では空爆や
砲弾
10弾地雷など
紛争の暴力によって人々が血を流して運ばれてきます
中には手や足がも切れそうな状態だったり
また爆発時に吹っ飛んだいろいろな破片物が体中に突き刺さってくるような状況だっ
たり
そして運ばれてくるときにはもうすでに亡くなっている方もいます
大の大人からお年寄り
インプさんや乳飲み子だって血を流して運ばれてきます
ある夜のことです
8人の子どもたちが一気に運ばれてきました
銃弾や空爆から身を守るために
昼間は家の中に閉じこもっていた子達が
夜になり音が止んで外に出て遊び始めたそうです
その時に内畑で転がっていた
面白そうなもの
うちらしいものを発揮してみんなで突いたり蹴ったりして遊んでいたそうです
ところがそれは時限爆弾でそこにいた子供たち全員の部屋足を2飛ばしました
私たち外科チームは朝まで8人の子供たちの切断手術
追われました
この写真は
自分たちにはもう手や足がないのだという現実を突きつけられる前のまだ麻酔から目が
覚めていないときの写真です
この50代の女性は空爆で旦那さんと4人の子どもそして自分の片足を亡くしました
麻酔から目を覚ました彼女が
私の顔を見て
死なせてと言いました
仕事中は泣かないようにしていますがこの時は彼女の手を握りながら泣いてしまいまし
た
この女の子があ
空爆の被害に遭った一人の一人として
集団で運ばれてきた時に家族らしき人物は見当たりませんでした
名前も年齢もわからないまま収容し
研究的に手術を行って命を助けることができましたが
混迷する風装置で身元の分からない彼女の運命は一体どうなってしまうのでしょうか
そもそも風装置では医療活動を行うということが簡単ではありません
本当に医療を必要としている人々のもとにたどり着くことが困難です
それは私たちの身の安全をも確保しなければならないからです
それに私たちがいくら中立の立場で医療を施そうともそこには障害も立ちはだかります
ここ珍念では医療施設が空爆をされるという事件も多発しています
たった一つの命令
たった一つのボタンによって落とされる空爆の空の下で
罪のない人々が
恐怖にさらされ
血を流し泣き叫んでいます
誰もが平等に与えられるはずの偉業でさえ
自由に施せない紛争地で
まったく戦争に加担をしていない人々の命をすくってもすくってもそして次にまた血
だらけの人が運ばれてくる
そのような
日常を繰り返すうちに私はこの戦争は止めなくてはいけないんだと思うようになりまし
た
ところが
私が行っている看護活動というのは
戦争を止めるための根本的な活動につながっていない
そのことに
大津ね自伝のを抱くようになってしまいました
そこで私は
人生の軸としていた看護師を辞め
夢だった国境なって石段をサリー
ジャーナリストになろうという大きな決断を下しました
自分が目撃しているこの県庁を国際社会に訴えて
戦争を止めるための動きにつなげようと思ったのです
ただ
私には
ジャーナリストになるという手段が全くわかりませんでした
そこで
実際のジャーナリストの人々に相談をしてみました
その結果
ジャーナリストになったからといって戦争を止められないよ
その仕事は自分たちが頑張っている
あなたは看護師でしょ
だったら
今すぐ現場に戻って
人々の命を救い続けなさい
そのようなことを言われ全く相手にしてもらえませんでした
途方に暮れてしまった私ですがでもそんな中でも
また紛争地派遣の依頼が来ました
そしてこの時の紛争地でてあった
17歳の女の子がその後の私の看護師人生の大きなきっかけを与えてくれたのです
この女の子は
戦争が始まる前までは普通に高校に通っていた女の子でした
ところが空爆に遭い彼女の足はめちゃめちゃに
総称しふさぎ込んでいました
そんな彼女を気にかけ私は手術室以外でも手を握り話掛け続けていました
まったく反応はなく彼女は一人
ベッドの上で傷の痛みそして心の痛みと闘っていたのです
そんな日々を過ごすうちに私にも帰国をしなくてはならない日がやってきました
そこで彼女に一緒に写真を撮ろうよと話しかけました
私はもう帰国をしてしまうけれどあなたの事を私は忘れたくはない
あなたの顔をずっと見ていたいからだから一緒に写真を撮ろう
そのように伝えました
そして
ついに彼女がは
やっぱのです
こんなに素敵な写真が開かれました
私は思わず彼女を抱きしめました
そして何よりもこの時に気づいたことをそれは私は看護師だからこの子の笑顔を見る
ことができた
看護師だからこの子の手を握り話掛け
だから見えた
ジャーナリストの仕事も大変とうとういです
でもやっぱり私は看護師なのだ
心の声に従い選んだ看護師という職業の素晴らしさに改めて気づいた瞬間だったのです
ふう装置において理想の医療などあり得ないと思っていました
物資も100際も人材にも限りがあり
なかなか思うように医療活動が進まない
その中で志さえも踏みにじられてしまう
そのように思っていました
医療で戦争は止まらない
それも本当にその通りです
ではその直言かで私たちに求められることは何だろう
私たちができることは何だろう
それはその時にできる
最善の医療を提供すること
その中で
手を握るとか話しかけるとか
それだけでもよるのかもしれません
手を握るということはその人を気にかける
その人に寄り添うということです
恐怖や絶望
憎しみ悲しみが交差する中で誰かがそばにいて手を抜いているそのことだけでも大きな
力になっているかもしれないと気づきました
私は先ほどの女の子の笑顔を引き出すことができました
これって私たちの日常にも通用することだとは思いませんか
困っていたり悩んでいたり
何かしらのチラさを抱えている人というのは何も紛争地のような極限下にいる人たち
だけとは限らないはずです
不安だと言ってる人に
安定さよ私よりも
眠れないと言ってる人にただ星3100を私よりも
痛いと言ってる人にいた日の女を与えるよりもそばにいて手を握るこのことだけでも
不安が軽減されたり痛みや辛さが減ったりするかもしれません
寄り添うということをもう一度見直して日本の社会にも取り入れていきませんか
もしあなたの隣に困っている人が入ったら是非その人のて追い切ってあげてください
ありがとうございました
[拍手]